Traduttore: Federico Sangati
Revisore: Federico MINELLE
Devo veramente scusarmi
perché avevo pensato di fare
il paragone tra Barcellona e Napoli,
il paragone dei livelli di felicità,
però quando mi hanno detto
che ho 10 minuti, ho detto:
"Vabbè Barcellona passa ancora
cinque minuti, ma Napoli..."
Detto questo, ho cambiato il titolo
che ora è "Emotion in the City"
e mi dispiace anche per questo,
perché l'ho lasciato in inglese,
una volta che lo avevo già fatto così.
"Emotion in the City" perché?
Anni fa con Maurice Benayoun,
questo amico francese
che è anche uno dei più grandi artisti
del digitale che esiste nel mondo oggi,
avevamo una discussione su...
"Mi piacerebbe" diceva lui,
"vedere in tempo reale
in tutte le città una grande mappa
per mostrare i punti dei problemi
in tempo reale
a partire da una quantificazione
di una serie di sensori".
L'idea era questa.
Anni dopo lui crea la prima cosa,
che è una simulazione,
prende 32.000 città distribuite sul mondo
e dà la possibilità alla gente in rete
di scegliere di scegliere,
tra 20 emozioni, 5 o 6
e chiedere la frequenza
di assegnazione di queste emozioni
alle varie città del mondo.
E costruisce così una mappa del mondo
dove molto approssimativamente
si può leggere il sentimento
average di questa zona.
Allora lui continua a lavorare
su questa idea e ha creato questo.
[Previsione dell'Emozione
di Maurice Benavoun]
Questa è una grande mappa a Parigi
che fa un paragone
tra il mondo dell'economia
e un mondo dell'emozione.
Crea, a partire dalla stessa
fonte d'informazione,
la predizione dell'emozione
dominante in una zona del mondo,
e sopra fa vedere anche
il movimento degli investimenti.
La dimensione satirica
è assolutamente chiara,
però l'interesse è davvero speciale.
Bene, andiamo alla prossima.
[rumori di fondo]
Questo non si vede bene,
e mi dispiace perché
non posso facilmente descrivere la cosa.
La posizione di Trento
è nel riquadro in alto a destra.
Si tratta di due misure
in una la smartness della città,
l'intelligenza average
e l'altra è lo stato
di benessere della città
e la corrispondenza
non è assolutamente ovvia,
però la buona notizia per Trento
è che si trova tra le più a destra
alla metà del quadro di destra superiore,
vuol dire che Trento si trova veramente
a una media molto alta
della smartness e della felicità,
ma la cosa che si vede è che le due cose
non vanno necessariamente insieme.
Adesso abbiamo una situazione
in cui l'emozione non è più locale,
è come l'opinione pubblica,
non è più locale è globale.
Vuol dire che le emozioni
circolano oggi grazie alla rete
creando una situazione emotiva
del pianeta che é assolutamente diversa.
Allora non faccio l'analisi
perché il tempo passa
però tutti questi, da Twitter
a Facebook a YouTube e tutti quanti,
ti portano emozioni per tutto,
che si condividono.
Infatti web 2.0 è un web relazionale
vuol dire un web
in cui la gente condivide emozioni.
La emozione normale della città
può essere puntuale,
come quella grande paura avvenuta
dopo la caduta delle torri di New York,
può essere organizzata,
come quello che è successo a Washington
quando per 23 giorni,
uccidendo almeno sette persone,
uno sniper terrorizzava
letteralmente tutta la città.
Però la cosa sorprendente
è che quando si usano dei big data
per sapere esattamente
che tipo di emozione o paura
preoccupi di più la gente,
vedete qui tre grandi picchi
rosso, giallo e arancio,
sono tre momenti di epidemia:
SARS, l'influenza aviaria e quella suina;
mentre a sinistra si trova
la parte più piccola
che era la paura del terrorismo,
la paura dell'11 settembre.
Questa è una cosa
che non si può immaginare,
si può sapere
attraverso una ricerca sulla rete.
Un'altra cosa assolutamente divertente:
questa è la mappa del capodanno
dell'anno scorso
che studiava in tempo reale
tutti i tweet a partire da parole chiave
che esprimevano un desiderio
per Capodanno.
Si vede in rosso
tutti i tweet che sono altruisti:
ti voglio bene,
voglio fare qualcosa per te,
mi piacerebbe quest'anno ...
Tutti quelli in blu sono narcisisti:
voglio fare più cose, la mia salute,
smetto di fumare;
quello verde: voglio fare più soldi.
La cosa interessante
è questa mappa emozionale
è il riflesso di emozione
di tutto un paese in un certo momento.
Mi sembra che sia una cosa pertinente,
come dire,
mi piacerebbe vedere sulla mia sveglia
questa mappa delle emozioni
del mio paese in ogni momento.
Allora ci sono emozioni globali;
voi sapete forse
cosa è successo con Free-Hug,
le persone che hanno incominciato
ad abbracciarsi nel mondo intero
perché un ragazzo di Sydney
ha avuto l'idea
di dare abbracci gratis nella strada
ed è divenuto un fenomeno mondiale
ormai dieci anni fa,
però è una delle prime
grandi emozioni globali.
Harlem Shake è una follia globale
e tutti voi avete certamente
provato questo [Gangnam Style].
Se vi interessa vi mando la slide
che spiega esattamente come si fa!
Bene, però c'è anche la rabbia,
l'emozione può prendere tutto il mondo.
"Inside Job" è un documentario
che ha fatto vedere
come gli Stati e le banche
si organizzano tra di loro,
per non dire una parola brutta,
senza fregarsi di noi.
Bene, detto questo,
succede che arriva,
a partire da questo sentimento
che cresce nel mondo o nella città,
un momento in cui
dall'emozione si passa all'azione,
cominciando da Barcellona
con Los Indignados
che hanno cominciato a protestare
in piazza Catalunya
contro questo gioco
delle banche e dello Stato.
Io adesso sono in partenza per il Messico
per discutere di un problema
che è vicino a questi temi:
come usare la rete per aiutare
il sentimento di comunità,
per avvicinare la gente della periferia
a quella del centro,
perché Città del Messico è una città
che è cresciuta in larghezza
non in altezza;
vuol dire che è enorme:
20 milioni di persone.
É una sfida capire come usare la rete
per creare un sentimento di comunità.
Questo è una delle più belle cose
che si possono dire
sulla felicità di un città
o di un paese.
Il re del Bhutan, nel 1972,
ha detto che è molto più importante
la felicità nazionale totale
del prodotto nazionale totale
e ha creato per questo
una scuola di pensiero
e un'applicazione di governo
che contiene una ricetta
che può dare la felicità
a partire da criteri
che possiamo vedere.
C'è prima di tutto
il sentimento di benessere interno,
il sentimento di equilibro emozionale,
di spiritualità,
chiaramente si tratta di un paese
che è molto vicino al buddismo,
e anche della conoscenza dei problemi.
L'altra cosa è l'uso del tempo,
il rapporto tra ore in cui si è svegli
e in cui si dorme.
La pratica della comunità,
la fiducia, il supporto,
anche la densità di questa comunità
e altre cose
come la vitalità della famiglia.
Tutto queste cose sono studiate
per vedere se le cose vanno bene.
Vuol dire che c'è una consultazione
tra popolazione e il governo
per assicurare che arriviamo almeno
a questo livello di felicità.
Io direi che questa è la norma.
Veramente, io la trovo
una cosa straordinaria.
Finiscono su un'altra cosa
del mio amico Maurice Benayoun.
[E-SCAPE OGGI]
[EMOZIONI DEL MONDO vs AZIONI IN BORSA]
Questo è la facciata
della stazione centrale di Seul in Corea:
lui ha ripreso la stessa cosa
per diffondere alla gente che passa
che finalmente
il nostro rapporto con questa vita
è un rapporto che deve portare
alla felicità piuttosto che al denaro.
É sempre in questo paragone tra i due
che penso stia arrivando,
nei vari suggerimenti sentiti oggi...
io vedo che c'è un cambiamento
molto profondo nella nostra società,
lenta, con problemi,
ma una tendenza, un'etica,
che potrebbe essere fondata
sulla felicità della gente e condivisa.
Io la vedo come possibile.
Grazie!